qu'on a planté
on va dire trois mois plus tard que
d'habitude
et on arrêtera les récoltes mi septembre
fin septembre au lieu d'arrêter fin
octobre comme d'habitude
[Musique]
le prix du gaz mais qui représentait
ici à peu près 25 à 30% des charges
s'ils ont continué à utiliser du gaz
cette année
à un chiffre d'affaires équivalent
l'année dernière on serait passé à 200 %
de charge de gaz par rapport au chiffre
d'affaires donc c'est ce n'est pas
tenable c'est vrai pas du tout
envisageable
[Musique]
avec le prix très élevé et bien
ici
plus de chauffage
et
[Musique]
aujourd'hui tout à 95% les tomates
cultivées en france sont avec ce système
aujourd'hui si avec les prix du
chauffage actuel ben demain cela veut
dire qu'on a pu une tomate qui va être
cultivée en france on aura plus du tout
tomates française aujourd'hui c'est déjà
une sur deux mais demain ça sera
peut-être moins d'une sur dix
[Musique]
c'est
petit
et
m